what's happening there reject nation
thank you guys so much for telling us
about this and the comments for our
spider-man into this across the spider
burst reaction because what i'm known
about wasn't for you apparently there
was this villains panel featuring willem
dafoe alfred molina and jamie foxx for
spider-man no way home and there's also
some new footage in it as well of course
excited check this out but when i got
back home from the event before all this
stuff started dropping i got this in the
mail shong chi steel book blu-ray comes
with the they didn't they're not paying
us to promote this i just want to show
you guys
4k ultra hd blu-ray copy i love steel
books go buy yourself a seanchi
steelbook blueberry copy i love this
cover i love the 10 rings design on the
back limited all right guys and one day
shanxi and spider-man will cross paths
let's see what's going on here let's
talk about it
[Music]
hi everyone i am tom holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and i am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new adventure in spider-man no way
home i know people say this a lot but i
mean it when i say that you're gonna see
things in this movie that you've never
ever seen before i believe we're talking
about pumpkin balls
[Music]
norman the multiverse which okay you
might have seen them before but i
promise
not like this and not together also
peter parker is finally heading off to
college and the word is out so yeah
everyone okay
so throw your fan theories out the
window they're probably not true or are
they
i get ready
an incredible story with lots of heart
laughter high flying action mind-blowing
effects and some insane villains no way
home is the culmination of the
homecoming trilogy and the start of a
multiverse of possibilities now i have
the honor of introducing some legends
please enjoy this exclusive panel with
my dear friends alfred molina william
defoe and jamie foxx here at ccxp now
before we do any of that we gotta look
at that new green goblin image
absolutely look at his face
that looks that's really great the aging
though yeah okay so he's gonna be hooded
yeah he's not gonna have the master
point that looks a lot more classic
green goblin outfit it's like he's got
the hood on and then the exoskeleton
type of suit he has it's like hatters
oh hell
yeah that's what i'm talking about
so yeah tom holland i think some
theories are going to be true
they've already been proven to be true
what excited you most about returning to
spider-man franchise and reprising these
iconic rose
you know what i was excited knowing amy
for years man and knowing what she's
done with this franchise and she was
explaining to me it's going to be hot
you know
and i didn't have to be blue and things
like
that characters concerns
and whatever like that and i get a
chance to hang out with these
these incredible test fielders but i
mean to walk on set man and to see these
guys i literally like bowed to them and
we just been having a ball
wielen how about you
willam
you know when i heard it i thought wow
that's pretty nutty uh i got speared
pretty good uh in the first film uh but
i thought okay they can figure out a way
to bring me back i bet it was really the
pitch and like jamie uh i know amy's
history uh she walked me through it and
then john
the director uh kind of pitched the
whole idea before i read a script and it
sounded like a lot of fun and a good
solution and then when we went deeper
into it i liked the idea that i was
returning to something
that was same but different it's a
return to something i did before
with that kind of history but the spin
there's a spin on it and that appealed
to me can i just say this is so trivial
i know right i just rewatched spiderman
wanted to and just to see alvaro molina
and william defoe sitting side by side
nor we're going to get them in the same
spider-man movie this is a culmination
we've been waiting for world of you is
retroactively losing their mind and i
mean jb fox like they have such great
rapport with all three of them you know
and jamie foxx yeah he's there he's
there
no i'm sure jamie foxx is gonna be
awesome in this alfred uh for me it's
just about the money
[Laughter]
oddly enough william and i were kind of
solid timing now 20 years since his
green first green goblin 17 years since
my first time as dark hark and these are
the longest options that a studio has
ever exercised from actors you know it's
like we've been waiting
but it's uh the material the pitch was
excellent and i to be honest when when
the idea was first suggested i my first
thought was hang on
i'm 17 years older i've got chins i've
got wrinkles you know i mean what you
know what are they going to do and and
then of course you i suddenly realized
wait a minute they've got the technology
this isn't going to be a problem but
it's it's been very nice to come back to
something that as you know is familiar
but at the same time completely new
because the technology has moved on
phenomenally since in the last couple of
decades especially for your kids
it's kind of still exciting
how did it feel to put the costume back
on
you want to know the truth
nobody knows how uncomfortable
but they look good we are actors you
forget about the discomfort and uh you
know
it's part of it um
but but the costumes are much more
comfortable than they were before
i remember the initial
um
uh fitting
to create the costume for the green
goblin i stood there for eight hours and
they put different uh pre-formed pieces
on me
now
they scan me and they can design it and
then make the costume and then try it on
me cool it's a huge
leap in the technology oh and they're
more flexible we can do more things with
them um
also i don't know how much we want to
fool with uh
spoilers but do it oh we love spoilers
full with it looks a little different uh
old norman and the goblin have uh are
further down the line and they have a
few more tricks up their sleeve so it's
not an exact um
there have been upgrades on the costume
let's say wear and tear
what upgrades i i'm
curious is it start tech because it
looks like mostly wear and tear i mean
he's had to probably like patch it
together to keep on trucking but yeah
i'm curious now to know they must do
something with the development of the
character because at some point we see
him in the trailer with the mask on it
if he's willing to operate without the
mask on so maybe something with the
forming of the helmet that they're able
to do this time around i'm just
theorizing here i don't know is it kind
of
yeah is it going to be the nanotech yeah
or is it going to be something else or
is it the kind of thing where he comes
to the universe he's got it loses it
somehow maybe there's a massive time
jump and it's like
a month later and he's living out on the
streets and he's roughing it in his suit
because it does look like more polished
and a little slimmer
but that's about it so i'm wondering
like what the what he means by some
extra gadgetry in some capacity the main
difference between that film and this
one
is that
the tentacles
are all kind of cg now they're all kind
of all be superimposed on me at a later
date whereas in the original movie
historically and i had them like you
know attached to me and we had
puppeteers working them and stuff so
that's the big difference but it's just
a great story it's a wonderful and it's
a wonderful world to be in you know it's
it's uh we're having you know if i say
so myself we're having a lot of fun a
lot of fun jamie
i'm happy we got a new new uh a brand
new start a brand new a brand new look
the the blue uh when we did it the first
time it was look look man i didn't i
didn't care i was just happy to be in
this wonderful course and it was like
you said it was you know
uh
sort of like two or three hours or
whatever like that but with this
this new this new new is fly the homies
is like okay now okay we get you now you
know i was blue they still roll with me
but okay you blue uh
but with this one
it it just feels more comfortable and i
think it feels more
uh
today modern like you know not trying so
hard like i i sort of related to r b
back in the day an r b used to have to
have fringes on your outfit and you know
and and like
shoulder pads and things like now you
can just you can sing you know so it's
like now we're just singing and you also
got an arc reactor now on your chest
yeah you got stark tech man yeah you got
a major in universe expansion it sounds
like from what they've talked about here
all three of them that all because of
the updates on technology and just the
overall design that it's allowing more
of a freedom of expression actors using
their whole body as instruments allowing
them to be more free
with uh being performers and that level
of comfortability is so important i
think for an actor especially when
you're dealing with roles like this that
require such imagination
so yeah that sounds great what do you
love most about portraying a villain the
the thing about grounded villains is
that and this is what ma what's so
wonderful about
the the villains in the marvel universe
if you like is that so many of them
become villains almost reluctantly
almost in spite of themselves by
accident it happens or some terrible
tragedy and it transforms them
and that's what makes them very playable
because it's not just mustache twirling
there's some real
depth to it and that's that's what makes
them interesting i mean in a lesser
environment us as villains we would just
be functionaries we would just be there
to you know get the plot going but here
we've got
real storylines we've got back we you
know we're we're they are real people
and so you know it's it's green goblin
has a uh case to state this time
he's trying to make his case mm-hmm a
philosophy of life it's not just about
some kind of abstract
muscle twirling power grab it's about
are you suggesting i'm a twirling
paragraph
okay i'm classically trained
yeah it's interesting to hear because
we're watching the first spider-man
movie and it's funny enough our friend
aaron whose shirt this is he was
pointing this out on instagram recently
too norman osborne seems to kind of drop
some motivation halfway through
spider-man one because it's like he's
pushed off the board and then he goes
after the board kills them and then he
just
wants to do villainous things he's just
evil i hate spider-man yeah yeah
that persona's taking over that much
more but yeah it's like his goal is kind
of accomplished yeah exactly so the
motives are kind of like swirling around
he was amazing in the movie from
beginning to end but the the motives are
not as clear-cut or crisp or especially
along the lines of even you know alfred
molina and spider-man too so it sounds
refreshing to hear that everyone here is
going to have a very integral personal
storyline i hope his case is just for
why he should be able to buy stark tower
yeah that would be good or maybe his
case is just back to formula
which villain is the most terrifying oh
man it's crazy it's crazy because like i
said we've just been watching
willem and it seems personal
because with because with electro it's
like electro and us it's to the world
the world did me wrong
but when something is personal and you
can go all the way back to shakespeare
when something is personal and that that
either that jealous thing there's
nothing that could beat that what
costume you put on no matter what you
say so when he when he speaks he has the
power and i think you'll really
but but i'm i'm being i'm being brave
it'd be different if i was blown up like
here's the thing but if i was blowing up
but here's his day but if i was blowing
smoke he'd know it here's the thing
it's personal and time you can get a
character to be personal in the movie it
has the most weight so ccxp is a fan
event is there anything you would like
to say to your brazilian fans
well i i mean if i may speak purely for
myself i think there is at some level
because we're professional people
there is some level where we don't want
to let them down
right right give them especially those
it's going to be worth their while
um but the fact that
a huge percentage of the audience are
comic book fans who know this world they
they love the the detail they love the
kind of the inside baseball of it all
right i think that's important to us as
well because you know we want to we we
don't want to disappoint that side of
the storytelling either
and so i think it's a sort of uh
symbiotic relationship symbiote they
give us
the chance to give them what they want
and that's uh i can't tell you it's just
so much fun whoa thanks guys
that's great yeah that's amazing really
great chemistry all three of them loved
it guys thank you so much for telling us
about that i mean they sounded very
sincere throughout this and it sounded
like they all had reasons to return more
than just money yeah
it seems like they all got a discussion
of what are we doing let's hear this out
first okay i like it now let's proceed
all right guys well thank you so much
can't wait for this movie less than two
weeks away subscribe click that bell hit
that like button and once we watch it
we're gonna try to get a review out
right the hell away we'll see you guys
soon